I knew how to defeat you once and for
all travel back in time kill you as a
child wipe you you are one-of-a-kind
eobard thawne and we don't mean not in a
good way you went back in time to kill
your enemy the flash when he was just a
kid that's pretty low even for you but
you missed your mark and got stuck in
the 21st century and to top it all off
you had to create what you swore to
destroy to get back home
Wow your plan really didn't work out now
did it Barry Allen does everything you
can to keep the people of central city
safe and Grant Gustin does everything he
can to keep the producers of the flash
happy the entire cast of the flash has
strict rules they need to follow or else
they risk being written off the show
keep watching to find out which
surprising rule keeps its actors looking
great in spandex
don't mess with the showrunner
showrunners are the backbone of every
television series and - believe it or
not but they call the shot the last
thing a showrunner once is to bump heads
with one of their lead actors and vice
versa the cast of the flash knows better
than to challenge their showrunner but
Katie Cassidy who played Laurel Lance on
arrow must have missed the memo because
she challenged arrow showrunner Marc
Guggenheim and wound up getting written
off the show in season four focus on
acting not on stunts every single
episode of the flash requires its fair
share of stunts but every now and then
the actors get used to the idea of
putting their necks on the line but one
of the most important rules the cast
that the flash has to follow is leaving
major stunts to professionals while fans
do love it when actors perform their own
stunts there are just too many risks
even small action scenes can lead to
injuries like when Grant almost got hit
by a spinning car during a simple stunt
scene don't get your hopes up no one is
more qualified to play Barry Allen than
Grant Gustin himself but if there's one
rule every actor portraying a superhero
must follow it's to never get your hopes
up you might be the first pick to play a
superhero on a TV series and the last
pick to play a superhero in a feature
film despite wanting to play the flash
in the DCU movie the role of Barry Allen
was recast save and behave if there's
one thing every actor knows all too well
is that job security doesn't exist
unlike some TV shows the cast of the
flash doesn't receive the biggest
paychecks and they're at the mercy of
the showrunners so if they start
misbehaving or acting like total drama
queens they can get written off the show
no matter how important they are to the
plot their roles aren't set in stone and
if they lose their jobs finding a new
gig can be difficult due to them being
typecast saving their paychecks and
treating everyone on the set the way
they want to be treated is the golden
rule don't believe the scrip most of the
time if your character dies in the
script it's time to say goodbye to your
role but that just isn't the case for
the cast of the flash tons of characters
have passed away in the script only to
make
come back in upcoming episodes since the
flash deals with alternate universes
time jumps and doppelgangers the cash
shouldn't believe everything they read
in the script just ask Tom Cavanagh time
to travel the flash is so fast he makes
travelling around the world look like a
total breeze but while Barry Allen only
needs two feet to challenge the speed of
light grant gustin and the rest of the
cast take public transportation just
like the rest of us since the flash is
filmed on location in Vancouver Canada
actors need to be committed to
travelling north of the border to film
the series failing to respect this rule
can result in characters receiving less
screen time or being written off
altogether always be acting actors were
born to put on a show but sometimes it
takes them a little while to realize
that making a fake means acting around
the clock their duties don't stop when
they walk off the set keeping the plot
top secret is of utmost priority so
public relations executives tend to
coach actors on which topics to avoid
the cast of the flash is responsible for
keeping controversy to a bare minimum be
open-minded the flash has one of the
most diverse casts of all time which is
something to applaud the actors have
gotten along famously since the get-go
and they're known for being extremely
fun to work with
the last thing producers want is a
closed-minded person challenging their
dynamic which is why being inclusive
kind and open-minded is a rule you can't
ignore keep it PG The CW has labeled the
flash as a PG TV show which makes being
apart the cast a little more restrictive
cast members aren't allowed to show off
a lot of skin in public because it could
give their on-screen counterparts a bad
reputation the spandex role Grant Gustin
has been body shamed in the past for
being on the skinny side and he's fought
back tooth and nail but the flash is
meant to be on the Sun side so grass
looks the part like most actors who play
superheroes grant has a regiment he
follows to stay in optimal shape chances
are if you're wearing spandex on TV
keeping fit is a role not a suggestion
who is your favorite character from the
flash sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap hit that subscribe button
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things we'll catch you next time
[Music]
[Music]